we start with good news this hour
minutes ago
johnson and johnson released results
from its phase three trial
of a covit 19 vaccine which could be
approved
for emergency use as soon as next week
it showed 85 percent protection against
severe cases of the disease
although the overall effective rate is
lower some advantages
it is a single dose and it can be stored
in a regular refrigerator and the new
vaccine is
effective against the strain of the
virus first discovered in south africa
and just detected in the u.s let's bring
in senior medical correspondent
dr tara narula tara good morning
good morning anthony the vaccine was
tested in more than 44
thousand people in the u.s latin america
and south africa
if authorized it would be a much needed
third vaccine
available in the u.s to meet the demand
that outpaces
current supply there's no question
that this vaccine is going to be a game
changer dr matai mammon global head of
pharmaceutical research and development
for johnson and johnson
is glowing about the results of the
company's phase 3
covet 19 vaccine trials the real world
effectiveness of this vaccine is apt to
be very high
data from those trials were based on
about 44 000 participants
out of which only 468 contracted covid
the study looked at protection against
both moderate and severe covet 19 cases
the vaccine candidate was 85 effective
in preventing severe cases of the
disease
in people of all ages and backgrounds 28
days after vaccination
and what we mean by severe covid is
feeling particularly sick at home
that's about 80 percent of the severe
cases or
in some cases being sick enough to go
seek medical attention
results also revealed protection against
multiple emerging virus variants
including the strain most recently
discovered in south africa
dr mammon says the numbers are
encouraging we had 85 percent efficacy
against serious cova disease
and that's meaningful because there's a
variant in south africa
that's particularly problematic so that
makes me
rest easier unlike the pfizer and
moderna vaccines which use mrna to carry
the code to make the coronavirus spike
protein
which allows the coronavirus to invade
human cells
the johnson johnson vaccine uses dna
the johnson and johnson vaccine also
uses a modified weakened cold virus
to gain entry into human cells this then
triggers an immune response
teaching the body to fight off the real
coronavirus
how is it that with the johnson johnson
vaccine we may only need
one dose we went through an experimental
process
and picked the very best one that
optimized for
neutralizing antibodies binding
antibodies and t
cells so we're able to get a lot more
immune response
than a typical single shot i would much
prefer
only to have to go in to get my one shot
rather than to have to go in
a month or three weeks later to get my
second shot bali palendron is an
immunologist at stanford medicine
who says a single dose vaccine can only
aid the biden administration's plan
to increase availability what sort of
public health impact do you think
having a single dose vaccine could have
i think the enormous public health
impact because
from a clinician's perspective it's so
much easier to administer
a single dose vaccine
the u.s government has pre-ordered about
a hundred million doses
but johnson johnson only expects to have
fewer than 10 million doses available
for february
we asked dr mammon about reports of
production delays he said the company
will meet the u.s order by june
and make a billion doses this year
globally of course the fda still needs
to review the data
to see if this vaccine is effective
enough for use
tara i think so many people would prefer
to take a vaccine that only requires a
single dose
do you think people should wait for that
johnson johnson vaccine
when it's authorized it's such a great
question and you know anthony at some
point we may have enough supply that
people can choose and wait we may have
data to suggest that
there's benefit in one population over
another but right now we are not in a
position in this country
to be thinking we're standing at a
buffet and we can choose every day that
goes by that somebody doesn't have a
shot in their arm
is the day that they're vulnerable to
dying the day that they're vulnerable to
becoming a long-hauler
a day that our country is taking longer
to reach herd immunity
so right now the best shot is the one
that you can get
as soon as you can get it i'll take the
first one that's available i'm with you
on that one
um it's very comforting that this is res
that this
vaccine is resistant to the south
african strain
pfizer and moderna are working on
booster shots to protect against
variants of kovid
do you think there might be some kind of
booster needed down the line or a second
shot ultimately
for the johnson johnson vaccine
it's possible you know johnson johnson
is currently conducting a study looking
at a two
dose regiment we don't have those
results yet but the good news
is that as soon as they're able to
sequence these variants
dr maman and other immunologists have
explained to us that it's very easy to
then alter the vaccine
to make it effective against strains
that may be
more difficult for us to fight off uh so
it's a it's an easy
fix potentially if we find those other
variants we're quickly concerned about
how soon do you think this this will be
authorized well it's possible that
within the next couple of weeks anthony
that would be good news all right dr
tara narula thanks so much